[Applause]  the nba playoffs on tnt  is brought to you by the all-new  sorrento from kia  official automotive partner of the nba  and by  burger king the new hand breaded chuck  king is here chicken  we're tied at 85 paul george  has made all five of his free throws  but donovich remains in there  with 13 points  [Applause]  and a change with ingles heading to the  bench  replaced by o'neill but tomb  sits kawhi leonard back in 193 playoff  games for carl malone  [Applause]  donovan mitchell is going to top that  number  and then some when it's all said and  done  it's a seven point game  still enough time for the clippers you  get this one cut it to a two possession  game  and put the pressure on your defense  bye